- GP, you've come up with
some new ways of saying
and doing so many things,
that I wanted to tap you
to come up with some
euphemisms or Drew-phemisms
to have some alternative words
'cause it turns out in
the daytime TV space,
there are only certain words you can say
and certain words you can not say.
Will you help me?
- Yes, I'll try.
- Okay.
All right!
(audience cheers)
Figuring out new language for daytime TV
with my friend, GP.
Okay, Gwyneth, our control room
is on standby to cut us off
if we say anything that goes too far.
All right, I need something for butt
because you're only
allowed to stay it once
and I just said it.
So help me.
Go, GP!
- Derriere.
- Tuchus
- Reserved seating?
(audience laughs)
- Builtin beanbag chair,
- The old Rumpelstiltskin.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- Two scoops.
(Gwyneth laughs)
- The great divide.
(Drew laughs)
(horn blares)
- (laughs) Okay.
Next, since we can't swear,
I need alternative, AKA
Drew-phemisms for curse words.
GP, go.
- What do we yell instead of a curse word?
Phooey!
- Crackers!
(laughs) Darn, darn my socks!
(audience laughs)
- Danga-a-lang-a-doo-dah!
- Jimminy Cricket!
- Jimmy Fallon!
(alarm sounds)
Our control room is going bananas.
Okay, we cannot refer to
another part of the anatomy,
and it starts with V and ends with ina.
GP, go.
- Lady bits.
- Fine China.
- (laughs) Pepperoni roll?
(audience laughs)
- Personal pan pizza.
- Life's cornucopia.
- I mean it is.
(Gwyneth laughs)
- Little pat a buttah.
(audience laughs)
(Gwyneth laughs)
- Lone mitten.
(explosion rumbles)
- In the honor of the Zucker brothers
and old school Nickelodeon,
"You Can't Do That on Television",
that was Drew-phemisms with
none other than the genius,
brilliant goddess Gwyneth Paltrow.
(upbeat music)
♪ Ah ah ah oh ♪